hello I'm Craig and I'm a developer in
this course we're gonna be exploring a
term that you've probably heard quite a
bit
that term is API or application
programming interface in addition to
being able to recite what it stands for
when you complete this course you'll be
able to discuss what an API does you'll
understand why they exist and you'll be
able to list the many benefits that they
provide you'll even get some hands-on
experience using a few popular web api's
which will give you a taste of what all
this excitement is about we'll be
starting from the very beginning so
there really isn't too much I'm gonna be
expecting you to know before starting
this course I would like to request that
you have a touch of experience with
coding and a wee bit of knowledge about
the web if you've written any program at
all even the typical first program you
know the one where you write the words
hello world if you've done that in any
programming language you'll be pretty
much ready for this course it'll be
helpful for you to have a basic
understanding of how the web works with
web servers and browsers but don't sweat
it we'll touch on this too now if you
haven't yet met these requirements
please check the notes attached to this
video for where to get started with some
beginning web and programming concepts
oh that reminds me you should probably
take some time to get used to your
learning environment the notes that I
just discussed are attached to this
video I'll also drop more information in
that section to keep you updated on what
might have changed from the time I
recorded this now I'll do my best to
remind you to look in there when there's
something that I think you just have to
see but you really should get in a habit
of checking that area out there will be
tons of juicy information there now
these videos have captions so if you
feel like you might benefit from having
those on please use them this space is
all yours if you want me to speak slower
use the speed controls this you don't
and if you and I'm taking too long of a
time just I make a pretty good chipmunk
and last but certainly not least take
advantage of the fact that you are in a
video based course if you needed me to
repeat myself use the video controls to
rewind me if you feel like you need a
break to let something sink in by all
means please
pause me I'll be right here waiting for
you I know that I've gotten into some
bad video viewing habits with all the
streaming media now well binging might
be a great way to consume an entire
season of your favorite show it's not
the best way to learn something new
education isn't meant to be benched and
because of this
probably reminds you quite a bit to take
breaks and encourage you to let what you
just learned marinate all right let's
get to it
API those three little letters generate
quite the buzz don't they now first I'd
like to take some time upfront here to
clearly break down what is meant by
application programming interface by
understanding its purpose and a touch of
its history I think you'll start to see
its importance and begin to understand
why this term keeps popping up in your
life after we get a good grasp on the
what and the why of api's we'll go and
learn how to explore two existing ones
we'll get familiar with a handy tool
postman which provides a nice way to
interact with web-based api's we'll use
that tool to hit an external web api to
send actual text messages and we'll get
some interesting data back from a
streaming music service api after some
practice using the api's we'll insert
them into a web application the
application we're going to be building
is a web app called complementor our app
will allow you to send compliments to
your friends your families and your
colleagues over text message and then it
encourages them to visit your site and
do the same now I've included the final
applications in both JavaScript and
Python and together we'll walk through
how to use external web api's to solve
the missing pieces we're going to be
strictly using api's in this course we
won't be writing our own now well you
most likely will end up learning some
best practices and API design we won't
be covering that specifically there are
many great courses available that show
the creation thought process and I've
linked to some of my favs in the notes
attached to this video in my opinion the
best way to start learning about any
acronym is to focus on each individual
letter for API I think we should start
on the last character the IEEE interface
let's talk a bit about interfaces that
you've seen already interfaces are all
around us for instance this radio here
it has a familiar interface the
interface allows me to do things like
change the volume change the station I
can turn it off and on I literally have
no idea how anything inside this thing
works but still the interface allows me
to control the way it works through the
options that are exposed the magic that
is happening is completely abstracted
away from me and I'm still in control of
what has determined that I user can
handle interfaces usually evolve over
time
like an alarm clock radio for example it
has my familiar volume and station
controls and it also adds some new
features like changing the time and
setting the alarm I still have no idea
how this works implementation wise but
the interface is something that I can
understand usually and as technology
evolves and new options come into
existence they make their way into the
new versions of the interface still
extracting away things for us but
enabling us to be in control of the new
features sometimes these physical
interfaces get so recognizable that they
even make their way into GU eyes did you
hear that there it is again
GUI or GUI graphical user interface this
is my streaming music app on my phone
and there's my familiar play button in
the user interface or you I and I know
what that play button does when I press
it but I have no idea how it does it and
I'm okay with that level of abstraction
I depend on it either what would I do in
public transit without music I can talk
to people hi how's it going
now the developer who wrote this
streaming music application of course
understands how the play button works
she coded the button so that when it
gets clicked the music starts playing
here's the thing though our developer is
also working with quite a few interfaces
that are abstracting away some of the
details for her for instance she wrote
code that happens when the button is
clicked she probably did that using an
event handler on the button what she
didn't have to do however was write the
code that makes the button interact and
change with the press she didn't have to
write the code that makes that familiar
clicking noise it was already there for
her buttons are in fact an interface
they provide the developer the means of
controlling its interactions while
abstracting away how that actually works
implementation wise this button is part
of the API or application programming
interface that's available from the
application framework that was used to
create the app because most apps need
buttons this interface has been created
to help our developer or application
programmer to use now by implementing
the button interface our developer was
able to make her code run when the
button was clicked it's worth noting
that the code probably also uses a media
player API that's provided by the
rating system of the device like Android
or iOS this media player API abstracts
away needing to understand the details
of how to send audio data to the
hardware the developer knows that they
just want to call the play method of the
media player API I suppose to the song
isn't stored on the device it's being
streamed over the network so a web-based
API call has been made over the Internet
to get the data it's actually api's all
the way down to the ones and zeros
providing abstractions at many levels
let's take a look at what all these
interfaces have in common they all
define ways for us to interact or
communicate with an object whether that
object be physical or software and as a
user of the interface we don't need to
understand the implementation we don't
need to know how it works
we just need to know what we've been
allowed to change or see interfaces
abstract away the implementation now
well the UI or user interface is made
for the user of the application the API
is made for the application programmer
to use and extend in their applications
with the I covered in our API let's take
a deeper look at the rest of the API
acronym an API is a contract of sorts it
defines how it's expected to be used and
it defines what you can expect to
receive by using it think of it as a set
of tools designed for software
developers like yourself an API is
created to help make your life easier by
giving you access to data and by
providing you with an abstraction of the
implementation you know not needing know
how it's doing whatever it's doing they
save you from needing to create
everything yourself
when designed well they make doing
nearly impossible things happen in just
a few lines of code you're probably
starting to see why it's important to
get familiar with them right I want to
do a quick word of warning here about
some naming issues that you'll probably
run into these days the term API is
almost always used as a way to explain
web-based api's in fact it's probably
safe to assume that when you hear API in
the wild it's most likely that people
are talking about a web-based API now
we'll explore those here in a few
however if we focus on all types of API
instead of just the web-based subset
we'll get a better
look into why web-based api's are so
popular so hang tight we're getting
there
ap ice are everywhere in your software
journey just about everywhere you look
your programming language whichever one
it might be provides many api's let's
take a look at one that's common in all
of them they all provide some way of
working with strings you know like a
series of characters you want to make
your text all uppercase just call the
API method and voila you could probably
create that uppercase string all by
yourself by doing some sort of low-level
bit math on each character but you don't
need to because your programming
language has abstract Adad away for you
and provided a handy string api it
exists because this is a common enough
problem that developers run into because
these programming language
specifications are just interfaces
different operating systems can supply
their own implementations so that the
code works properly in their environment
I think an easy way of picturing this is
to think about how different operating
systems like Windows or Mac OS maintain
their files they're totally different
yet your programming language provides a
single API for working with the file
system you can write one script and it
works in either Mac or Windows it's the
implementation that takes care of all
the details for you pretty cool right
definitely something to be thankful for
it makes our life so much easier not
having to worry about what operating
system is being used the importance of
an API to a language cannot be
understated there's been some
fascinating legal cases where it's been
questioned if the language API itself
again not the implementation can be
copyrighted
check out the notes for more on that
along similar lines there are different
web browsers you know like Google Chrome
Microsoft edge Safari Firefox and brave
now you might not have pondered this
before but isn't it amazing that you can
write code for the web and it will work
in any of them now this works because
there's a set of web api's that web
browsers all must implement in order to
make that magic happen for you we're
standing on the shoulders of giants
folks we really should thank those
giants more often there are authors and
maintainer zuv libraries that package up
code and solve common problems so that
you don't need to do it yourself like
for instance do you know how to
programmatically make a photo black and
white me neither but I can download and
import
an image packaged into my application
and suddenly I can I just call a method
and boom
I wish real life skills work this way
I'd import dancing so I could be more
fun at weddings cha-cha-cha frameworks
provide an API that allow you to extend
what has been provided to make it your
own
like for example most web frameworks
provide you with the ability to add a
new route to your web application it
allows you to write out dynamic data to
a template that you specify and you do
all of this with just a handful of lines
of code you don't need to understand how
it's doing things but you do need to
know how to write an implementation to
what the framework is expecting in this
case you're using the API the contract
to write a valid implementation that
meets the requirements and all these API
is that we just talked about they're
local to our codebase they exist within
our code we use them to avoid recreating
the wheel that is to say they assist us
in accomplishing tasks that we need to
perform by abstracting away a ton of
work for us the stuff that we developers
shouldn't be worrying about we should be
focusing on the business problem at hand
and that means a big part of your job is
figuring out how to leverage these api's
to your advantage now I think it's an
excellent time to take a quick break I
just gave you a lot to think about and
I'd like you to take a minute to breathe
why don't you jot down some api's that
you've used today even if you weren't
coding I know that you've seen some in
action if you're having a hard time
thinking of some I'll give you a hint
you're watching a video right now inside
of a web browser when a return will
explore the concept of remote api's ones
that aren't executing locally in our
code base and why that's such a powerful
concept
[Music]
it took me a while to find this remote
control it was in the couch it's always
in the couch anywho this remote has an
interface on it right there's the power
button and there's a channel changer and
when I press the volume button it sends
my request to my device and the volume
changes as if I turn the volume up using
the interface on the device itself and
we know why that's important
I want to remotely control my device and
I want to get up from the couch there
are of course more or less lazy reasons
as to why you might want to remotely
control objects this cute little robot
for instance has a remote API you can
send commands to it and it responds it
even sends back sensor information these
traffic signs can change based on an API
call this drone here is actually remote
controlled by an app on my phone see
it's not just physical objects that
benefit from remote api's oftentimes we
don't have space on our local machines
for all the data that's available like
for example have you ever used one of
those apps that helps you figure out
what song is playing you send up a
snippet of a song you heard playing at a
grocery store using your microphone and
it sends back exactly what the song is
it's usually Phil Collins turns out both
grocery stores and yours truly loves
Phil Collins you don't have room for all
the songs in the world on your phone and
with this remote API you don't need to
have all of them it does all the
searching and processing and it's
surprisingly quick how can it possibly
do that I don't know but I love the
interface it's so fast oh there's
another benefit of remote api's
computational power because an API
removes the limitations of your local
machine you can gain access to seemingly
infinite amounts of power a good example
of that is the AR app of Google
Translate you can use the camera on your
phone in a near real-time it's able to
translate directly to your screen like
instantaneously it's using a ton of
processing power to make this magic
happen
and that processing is happening
elsewhere in la nube it took quite a bit
of experimentation in some evolution of
ideas but over time we finally turn this
remote API dream into a reality
now I'm going to drop some history and
the teach
but I just want you to know that the
struggle to achieve this concept of
remote api's was very real now most of
the problem was that there wasn't a
standard that everyone loved things were
pretty clunky for a while as the ideas
were sussed out but then it happened a
new architectural style appeared that
was clear and allowed us developers to
interact with specific resources over
the web and it quite literally changed
everything
this style rapidly emerged as a winner
and just about everyone began offering
and consuming api's over the Internet
and what I'm talking about here is rest
or representational state transfer it
was the approach that we needed and
honestly it's the abstraction that we
developers deserved like we talked about
already the popularity of rests spread
so rapidly it nearly completely overtook
the term API it's like how we use the
word Xerox to mean photocopy even though
Xerox is just a brand of photocopier
Xerox does other stuff too yeah I think
that's how pervasive rest is rest is for
sure not the end-all be-all of remote
api's there are definitely some
limitations which we'll discuss here in
a bit
technology is ever-evolving and of
course there are movements that are
still advancing the concept of the best
remote api's some turns you might have
even heard like graph QL more on this in
the teachers notes for the rest of this
course we're going to be doing a deep
dive into api's that are written using
the rest style when api's embrace the
style and constraints of rest they're
said to be restful cute right if you're
feeling like you need a little rest go
ahead and pause me before we do a deeper
dive into what it means to be restful
sorry that was a bad and obvious joke
and as a developer you kind of have to
make it you don't really have an option
and because rest sits on top of web
technologies we should probably do a
whirlwind refresher of how the web works
[Music]
it might have been a while since you
thought about how the web works there
are a smattering of terms that I'd like
to reload into your working memory
before we talk more about how rest uses
them so let's use the web I've got my
computer here and on it I have an
internet browser this browser is a web
client and I'm going to use it to
connect to a server I'm going to do this
by putting a location in the address bar
a universal resource locator or URL to
be exact you might also hear this
referred to by a superset term URI or
universal resource identifier now our
URL here has a scheme portion and this
one happens to be HTTP HTTP stands for
hypertext Transfer Protocol let's break
that down a bit let's grab that last
part protocol a protocol is also often
like into a contract it's a little lower
level than an API but it's similar in
concept you can think of it as defining
the expectations of how to communicate
an example that I find really sticks
with me is if you've ever been to a
rally and someone does one of those
chants where they go when I say foo you
say here let's do it when I say HTT you
say p HT t HT t oh I just realized I
might have made you yell P out loud I
hope you're in a coffee shop that'd be
awkward anyways we you and I we just set
up a real quick protocol I told you how
to respond to my specific requests you
would have been breaking our agreed-upon
protocol if you yelled anything else but
P so that browser creates an HTTP
request for you along with the URI it
also specifies a particular HTTP verb in
this case it's using the Det verb which
is used to clarify that this request
will only receive data that is it won't
be making any changes the server
receives the request that was
transferred from the client there's that
second T the server then does the work
that it needs to do
finally it generates the resulting
webpage and sends back a response to the
client my browser in this case now the
most important part of that response is
the body for a web page that contains
the HTML or hypertext markup
language which gives us the remaining
parts the HT of our acronym hypertext is
text that can link to other text in HTML
we perform that linking with anchor tags
so with that response the browser
renders the page when one of those links
are clicked they kick off a brand new
HTTP GET request and the process repeats
itself over and over in between those
clicks though the protocol is done we
made the request we got the response
HTTP as it was originally designed is a
stateless protocol once that request
receives a response it's all done if you
want to keep some sort of state your
client will have to manage that itself
and send it up with each new request
check the notes for more on this there
are more HTTP verbs also known as
request methods besides get most common
scenario you see is when you encounter a
form that is used to take information
from you typically you'll see the verb
post used to explain that you are
submitting or posting data to the server
okay so our protocol that's used to
transfer this hypertext is admittedly a
little more complex than our rally chant
was there's quite a bit of important
information that's included in both the
request and the response you've probably
seen query string parameters and URLs
you know the stuff after the question
mark this is one way to pass information
about the request another common way
this information is passed around is
through specific key and value pairs
called headers both requests and
responses have headers and they're used
to help further communicate what is
wanted as well as what has been sent
back now some of the popular request
headers allow you to specify information
about the content that you'd expect back
like the language or the type of content
you can also state you only want a page
if it has changed since a certain time
this technique allows for caching which
is a powerful concept why get the whole
page if you already have it in your
local cache you can embed authentication
information in each request using a
header this way you are essentially
keeping your client logged in across
requests the response also contains
headers a super important one is the
status code this lets you know what
happened on the server side and it could
convey things like missing documents I'm
sure you've seen the old 404 error the
page has been moved or hopefully
everything is a 200 ok it can
also explain the content-type how large
the data returned it is and many more
things okay got it feeling good about
that little whirlwind to her remember
feel free to make me repeat myself
if that was way too much I totally get
it that was a lot of information it's
important to have a basic understanding
of these things because rest sits on top
of them it uses the concepts that were
introduced with the web to expose
resources that can be accessed and
manipulated let's take a look at how the
restful approach takes advantage of the
web and it's tooling for your benefit
and profit rest stands for
representational state transfer api's
that meet the rest architectural style
constraints are considered to be restful
a typical way to teach about restful api
is to cover the constraints that define
it all up front I don't know about you
but personally I find approaching
learning that way pretty overwhelming
especially from the beginning I mean we
haven't even looked at an API yet and on
top of that most of the REST API is that
you use will meet all of these
constraints so here's the thing I
promise that we'll go over all the
constraints let's do it on our own time
like don't learn them all right this
instant we can even make it a fun
journey like a restful constraint
scavenger hunt complete with prizes here
are the guiding architectural
constraints required for an API to be
considered restful well check them off
when we discuss them and then we'll loop
back once more at the end and review got
to collect them all sound fun good let's
get started talking about how REST API
sit on top of web technology like a
little hat much like the web the client
makes a request to a server the client
in this case is typically going to be
your program and you'll probably be
using some sort of library to create the
request of the server
the protocol used is you guessed it HTTP
and it's stateless the server won't
remember anything about the particular
client if you want to maintain state
like your login details you must send it
with each and every request and you'll
do this using headers and just like that
we talked about two of our rest
constraints client-server architecture
and stateless you've got to knocked off
already you're on a roll now we should
probably talk about what that request
was requesting right well
most certainly was requesting
information about a resource a resource
is a little abstract and that's
intentional
it's the are in the URL or URI we use
the term resource to reference an object
which also happens to be pretty abstract
right this is because we can use
resources to describe just about
anything that we build for instance
let's imagine an e-book store website on
the home page maybe there's a list or a
collection of new books each of these
books is a resource now we click into
that to take a closer look at the book
resource and we see a link to the author
which is also a resource we click into
the author resource and we see a
collection of all the other books that
they've written maybe we even see a
group of fans again another collection
and each of those fans are a resource
clicking into a fan resource we can see
the collection of their favorite authors
and books everything is a resource
let's change gears how about an image
sharing application on our phone so we
have user resources those users post
photos which are resources and the
photos can be loved so there's a lover
resource maybe there's an album that can
be created there's an album resource
that contains photo resources and albums
have a collection of contributor
resources turns out almost everything we
ever want to build can be expressed in
terms of resources and collections most
of what we want our applications to be
able to do to their resources can be
expressed through the unfortunate
sounding acronym crud and that stands
for creating reading updating and
deleting now as a user of the e-book
site all we did was a bunch of reading
no pun intended
actually I didn't end that one we were
reading right just getting the
information to display like we retrieved
the author page we made a read request
for that page the web browser used a get
request to that specific author page now
the restful api follows the same logic
your program sends a get request to a
uri then the server responds with data
and of course all the HTTP headers that
you've come to know and love and the
body is typically represented these days
as JSON or JavaScript object notation
JSON provides a great
way to structure and nest your data
every programming language that I can
think of provides some means of turning
a JSON string into a native object
content type is typically something that
you can specify in your request
if JSON isn't your thing now if you
recall there are other HTTP verbs
available these verbs are used in REST
API is to clearly state the intention of
your request want to add an author posts
to the slash authors and send the data
that you want to update in the body of
your request these fields will be
defined for you somewhere want to remove
an author send and delete to that
specific author updates typically
support the patch verb and you'll see
we're able to represent crud the create
read update and delete using HTTP
methods pretty cool right what this
means is that you can interact with any
application out there that's exposed
their REST API you could grab data
remotely automate tasks and even smush
services together this is called a
mashup and here's the thing there are
tons of API is available just about
anything you could imagine and if
they're truly restful they'll all feel
pretty much the same you can build
anything there are services that allow
you to do incredible things with a few
simple API calls so now the question
becomes what are you going to build why
did you take a quick break and when you
come back let's explore a restful api
together we'll take a peek at how to use
the music streaming service Spotify and
their excellent
restful api
[Music]
you have some newfound understanding of
how web-based api's work I walked you
quickly through some imaginary rest
api's and now i'm thinking it's time
that we get a little more specific why
don't we go exploring together some of
these rest api is allow you to give it a
try from the comfort of your very own
web browser and one of my personal
favorites that allows for exploration is
the streaming music service Spotify so
here I am at Spotify comm and a quick
word of warning this for sure is going
to look different by the time you get
here there are teams of people working
on the site to make it better and you're
gonna have the benefit of a better
website than I have right this instant
so just a reminder you should check the
notes attached to this video for any
breaking changes and if you don't have a
Spotify account yet don't sweat it as
you can see it's free and that same user
that you can create you can end up using
for development purposes so let's assume
that I didn't know that Spotify had an
API now what I usually do is I look
around
so typically most sites store the nerdy
stuff down here in the footer there we
go
developers that's what we're looking for
it's a community of developers that's us
let's do it Wow I love a site that
treats me well even as a developer this
is really nice right so you can do a ton
of stuff since I was last here let's
take a look here from the front so audio
analysis wow you can learn about dance
ability maybe I will be able to install
that skill after all oh cool audio
playback so you can kind of nice you can
embed a player right right in there you
can put a player into your your
application an SDK here that stands for
software development kit and we'll look
at one of those here in a bit but
basically what it does is it gives you
an API that wraps around other api's and
it will feel native to your programming
language cool and then let's take a look
here at recommendations Oh awesome it
will give you specific recommendations
awesome this is great target dance
ability I'm gonna be able to dance
and see this JavaScript here it's doing
a get to one of their end points awesome
this looks good
so let's take a look up at the top here
let's go ahead and discover that's what
we're trying to do we're trying to
discover what we're gonna do with this
API so let's let's click into here and
this will give us some ideas of what we
can do let's see real apps that
integrate audio features into this is
awesome I love when sites do this I find
that it's a great way to get inspiration
if you don't yet have an idea of how you
might use the API you can see how other
people have used it cool so this is the
audio analysis that we had seen a quick
dashboard of audio features of songs and
is that dance ability again here's
playback so you can get a player this is
super neat and these are apps that use
them iPhone app a listening room
RunKeeper
so you can see here this is for iOS and
this is for android-based phones so iOS
being like mac based products and this
is Android based products and this is
widgets I'm not exactly sure what that
is I'm assuming that's the HTML widgets
that we had seen and that's cool right
because it's a web based API all we need
to do is to connect to it over HTTP so
any of these devices can connect to it
pretty slick all right let's keep going
so we've got recommendations that's
great I always need music
recommendations search ooh that's nice
that actually feels like a good place to
get started right like if we went we
searched for different things so there's
six degrees of Kanye West yes a lot of
people are connected to him find other
artists that are like the artist you
like this is great why don't you say we
look at some of the documentation for
search so I'm gonna click this read the
docs let's read the docs
oh nice now you might not see this but
there's a brand new Web API reference in
beta which means it's not quite ready
for everybody but it's ready for people
to try I'm gonna go look at that you
might actually be there and be out of
the beta period by the time you see this
okay so let's take a look and let's see
about this Search API let's see
Search API so let's go ahead let's click
into there as you use more and more
api's you'll get super familiar with
reference documentation like this this
is explaining the contract of what we
need to do to use this API so you'll see
here that there's different parts so
this is what the request is that we're
going to be sending and it's saying here
that this is a header and this says
whether or not things are required and
this indeed is required so this is
authorization here there's a header
that's required in the request for
authorization the authorization means it
knows what you're allowed to do or
authorized to do Spotify and many other
api's use the concept of access tokens
so then so that's a header that's the
header that's required and so here we
see this query parameter right so query
parameters and you'll see that this
one's required this queue so this is the
search query the keywords right so and
here's an example of what that is and
this is showing you that it needs to be
URL encoded there's some more notes on
this here in the bit so note we have cue
is required and also type is required
and type is like album artist playlist
like the type of resource that is
available in Spotify is API
and if we keep scrolling down there are
more there's more optional query
parameters that are available really
help you specify your search very rich
API they have and then it shows you this
response so this is what's going to come
back so you'll see that you'll get a
header and the status code very
important we'll say 200 ok if it's good
on success rate on success or don't say
200 ok and the response body contains an
array so like a list of artist objects
or album of whatever was the type you
were looking for and it's gonna be in
JSON format just like we talked about
javascript object notation
and so you'll see when there's an error
there'll be an error code and the body
will have the error message and then
there's some more notes here and these
are really thorough this is great so i
encode spaces that's what we saw we saw
that percent 20 it's making sure that
you can't use a space otherwise if it
breaks the URL so this is how you do
that you'll see there's lots of
different information here yeah you can
use Asterix and Shirley and all sorts of
ways to do fun queries let's go ahead
and try this out in the web console it's
pretty slick so what this does is it
lets us search for an item and it's
showing us how it's doing it's doing a
get and it does have some authentication
required so we will need to build
something here but you'll see over here
it's showing what it's doing it's doing
a get to this URL and this is code here
that will actually run and you'll see as
we change the fields here so I'm gonna
change this to a very popular artists
around my house lizzo and you'll see
that it updated over here it updated my
query and the type is set to artists
already so that's fine and we have this
oo auth token that we need to get so we
need to get this token so again this is
the what are they authorized to do so
we're gonna go and choose get token in
it's it's telling us that this specific
endpoint doesn't require any specific
scope so these are scopes that you can
do so when you build this token it's
saying for using this key these are the
things that the people are able to do
and we don't need to do anything
specific for this so let's just go ahead
and let's not check any of these we
don't need to modify a private playlist
we don't need to do that so we're gonna
do request token and here it's gonna ask
us to log in to Spotify
and if you have Spotify go ahead and log
in and if you don't remember it's free
you can totally just come in here and do
sign up and we can put in our emails
here so I'm gonna put in mine and here's
a little trick if you don't know this
yet I'm gonna put in API course
let's do API course like this at
gmail.com my email address is Craig s
Dennis at gmail.com but if you put a
little plus here you can kind of
categorize things your own so just a
little trick and that way if you're
worried about emails coming in you'll
know that they're coming in from address
I'm gonna do the password to my luggage
which is one two three four or five just
kidding
what should we call you I love it when
you call me Big O all right so my date
of birth is November 19th and I was born
in the wonderful year of 2000 just
kidding this is awesome I love this
Spotify
thank you for being inclusive
inclusivity matters I'm gonna choose
mail I don't want to share my
registration data and I am NOT a robot I
promise
I think I'm not a robot identify the
crosswalks
what is that all right so there's one
it's definitely across well if that's a
crosswalk I mean I could walk across the
street here I could I passed I sign up
here we go let's save that password well
I got to turn on sync I logged in as Big
Poppa here we go so I'm gonna click
agreed I'm gonna pop back to the page
and you'll see now this is filled out
now one thing I do want to point out
here is that my token here my key is on
the screen and if a hacker were to pause
my screen and copy that down they could
essentially do things to my account on
my behalf but I of course know that and
I'm gonna delete this token later
remember this is like leaving your car
keys on your driver's seat
you probably don't do that so treat
these keys the same and keep them safe
and with you so I could just copy this
whole command and paste that into my
terminal and it would work we'll do that
in a bit but what I want to show you
first is that you can do this try it
button here and what happens is what
comes back is this beautiful JSON so
you'll see that what's being returned
here is as artists and it's an object
that has the search that we built and
then here is this items and you'll see
that it's an array because there could
be multiple artists named Liz oh and I
guess looks like maybe there is yeah it
looks like there's actually another
artist named Liz Oh popularity 88
and once this Liz's popularity
her John has escaped roof and I feel old
one thing we can do is we can look and
see if this uh there's these external
images so you can kind of take a look
and see if it's them I'm gonna click go
to here and we'll see what happens and
there she is
Liz Oh is on all the time at our house
once my daughter's figured out the Alexa
could play music
they're like Alexa play whizz Oh Alexa
by the way is a voice user interface
right there's the eye again so I'm gonna
get back to our tab and we will go now
and we see here that she has an ID
because we're in this artist right so
should we see her that she has this ID
I'm gonna go ahead I'm gonna copy this
you also see that there's another API
call here that we can do there's a href
that will get her specifically right so
there's the slash artist and there's a
flasher ID so if we called that it would
get information about her again I'm
gonna make sure that I copied her ID
here I'm gonna scroll down a little bit
more think there's the other Liz oh
let's look so thing where we can look at
the page yeah here we go
so here's external URLs and you'll see
this is on the API this is the actual
Spotify page itself so if I'm gonna do
this and I'm gonna right-click and I'm
gonna say go to this is Liz's actual
page and this is how it's displayed
right as a as a web page on Spotify if
we scroll down here we'll see that
there's this popular there's your
popular songs good as hell
great stuff if you don't know her use
this link learn her
I happen to know that we can get a list
similar to these popular songs using the
API so let's go back to our reference
okay so we're back here in our reference
let's look at the artists API so we're
going to click on artists and again I'm
going to go into the the beta Web API
reference might be what's live for you
and I'm gonna click into the artists API
over here
I'm gonna scroll down a little bit so
there's get an artist getting artists
albums and what else do we have get an
artist tops tracks this is exactly what
I wanted to do okay
so again here's the docks about that I'm
gonna try this out in the web console
okay so get an artist tops tracks it's
gonna do a get and this is the end point
so we're just going to needs that ID
right so we're gonna put that ID in
there it's coming defaulted with
somebody's so I'm gonna go ahead and
paste Liz O's in there okay and the
country is us and you'll see that again
it's changing so see how the IDs here
countries us and we're gonna pass that
our private keys along and I'm gonna
click try it alright so now we've got a
list of tracks and each one of these
tracks has what album it showed up on ok
so again there's the this will be in the
same list they're top tracks as we saw
on that page which is super neat right
there's the cuz I love you song yeah
let's keep going a little bit you'll see
how the you are eyes here they they use
a different style you are with the the
Colin's two separate but it's Spotify
artist and then the ID then we'll see
here that there's this preview URL which
you could actually just go ahead and
open and it will start playing this song
pretty cool right you can get access to
all of Spotify music library and you can
build tools that extend their platform I
highly recommend that you go and take a
look at what people have built using
these api's super impressive did you
notice how fast those results came back
how could it do that search so quick oh
wait a second it does it even need to
the results don't change all the time
it's not like lizzo is dropping a new
song every minute though I wish you
would those results are definitely
cashable ding-ding-ding cache ability is
also available on the client and we'll
get to that here in a bit but this is a
great example of a layered system I'm
almost positive that Spotify has set up
things so that it returns that same JSON
from its own server-side caching
mechanism
it's not rendered on every request now
as a user of the API I don't know how
it's doing that and frankly I don't care
I want it to be available in fast when I
hit that specific URL and as lizzo might
ask baby how you feeling I'm feeling
good as hell that was fast
Spotify is just one REST API there are
tons and tons of services out there
there are even services that exist only
as api's let's go ahead and take a quick
break I'd love for you to take some time
and think about what you might be able
to build with the Spotify API for
instance well I was using the API I had
this idea pop up I'm often at festivals
and I'm having a hard time figuring out
which band I should go see there's so
many I'd love to have an app suggest me
which of the bands that are playing that
I would most likely enjoy based on my
listening cabinets I'm pretty sure you
could do that just by using the Spotify
API and a list of the bands performing
if you end up building this app please
share with me what other interests you
have that provide an API that you can
use check the notes for more ideas after
you come back from your break let's dive
a little deeper and make use of an API
using our own tools see you soon no
really take a quick break seriously I'll
do you good
no binging well I realize that exploring
an API on a website is informative it
might not feel like you're actually
using that API I think the next logical
step in exploring is actually making
that request yourself from your computer
not from a website let's use a different
API this time let's use Twilio Twilio is
a company that loves api's in fact
that's most of what the company is it's
a company for developers that helps
abstract away telephone communications
well actually all kinds of communication
channels it lets you bring
communications into your applications it
allows you to make and receive calls and
text messages and a whole slew of other
things I need to be a little upfront
with you here I love Twilio I mean I
love it so much I even applied for a job
with them and I got it
but even if I didn't I would
still show you how cool their api's are
I mean with a single command you can
send a text message I remember when I
first did that I was like wow that level
of abstraction is amazing how does that
work with all the different cell
carriers the varying standards and
networks I have no idea and I don't need
to that's the beauty of this API let's
get started
so I'm here at Twilio comm and again a
word of warning this will most likely
look different as Twilio is constantly
making improvements so please check the
notes for any changes to this flow so
first things first let's sign up we'll
be able to use a free trial account for
the rest of this course let's sign up
with my information I am Greg and again
I'm gonna use that trick some say Craig
has tennis plus let's say API course
case I've already done that one at
gmail.com and I will set my password too
and I am going to accept the terms and
services because I've read that and I'm
gonna start my free trial save my
password there we go and it's sent an
email to my gmail I will go check that
real quick there we go I've got a email
and I am going to click that link let's
do this we will paste it here verify my
account and I am logged in alright so
I'm gonna put in my phone number which
is five out of three four six one five
five three seven and this phone number
you probably use for authentication for
the toilet concert somebody might
contact me a free onboarding that sounds
great I'll check that click verify so
seven oh eight six five five
so in travel mode we can only
communicate with numbers that we
verified so do you write code I do I
write code all right I write Python code
my goal today I'm gonna use it in a
student or a hackathon project for sure
I'm gonna send or receive SMS SMS is a
short message service which is text
messages we're gonna send text message
so the weight Twilio works is you buy an
actual phone number let's do it so we'll
get this trial number here this number
got automatically selected it's fine by
me 201 five eight four eight zero eight
nine and I'm gonna choose it let's say
choose this number and just like that
the numbers mine and I can program it
and we'll do more with that later so I'm
gonna click done so there's some notes
here right you can only send messages
and make calls to verified numbers
that's how our Twilio trial account
works right notice also we have fifteen
dollars which is more than enough for
money to do anything we're gonna do in
here and it's also says that messages
and calls include a note about this
coming from Twilio trial account okay
that's why what do you say we send a
text message let's do it so the way that
things work is over here there's a
little menu and we have different things
as you can see there's a bunch of stuff
available we're gonna choose this very
first one here this programmable SMS
short message service I am also going to
pin that to the dock so that I can get
to it easier so it'll always be there
okay so you'll see here it's pinned I
want this page I'm gonna choose get
started let's do it now this step allows
us to explore the API like we saw on the
Spotify site you'll see as I change
things here so let's change this body to
say
hoy you'll see that it changes the code
that's over here fun note here the
Hawaii was the first word ever spoken
over the phone so a Hawaii is kind of
like hello world of phones so I'm gonna
go ahead and click make requests and I
got the text
of course it's prefixed with sent from
your Twilio number but whoa right I just
sent a text by President button let's
take this a step further I'm gonna copy
this code and actually first before I do
that I'm gonna check this show your auth
token just like Spotify Twilio uses auth
tokens and they're private keys but I
trust you and also I'm gonna delete this
later I see you hackers so now if I come
over here and I click this copy this
copy icon here it will be in my
clipboard now I'm running on a Mac so
I'm gonna open up my terminal and I'm
going to paste so see how this is the
URL that we are going to post to right
we're going to post because we're going
to be creating a new message notice here
this is my account Sid or string
identifier and because we have JSON here
this dot JSON that tells the toilet API
to return JSON and we use form URL
encoding here this with this data URL
encoding is and this is the - we're
gonna send it to my phone number and
it's gonna be from our Twilio number and
the body's going to be Hawaii so I can
come in here and I can change this code
right so I can instead of a whole way
I'm gonna make it say ahoy from terminal
and this - you here is setting up the
authentication of the account set and
this is my off of token so when I go
ahead and press Enter we'll get some
information back and it tells me that it
was successful it will it will give an
error if it didn't I got my text message
so this command is sending a post which
is great but I can also use get to
receive the messages that have been sent
so kind of like a sent log
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to use
the up-arrow I get the the information
back I'm gonna change this to get and
then I'm gonna get rid of the rest of
these lines which I'm going to do with
get in here new control ke the Mac look
in the notes for how to do this in
Windows so we're gonna say all of the
messages that were sent to this and if I
go press Enter
that didn't work because I left at the
trail at the end I'll just press up
again I'm gonna get rid of this trailing
slash cuz that means like continue over
the next line so here we go oh I need to
have my count said so let's do that
again
let's go press up a couple times so I
forgot that I need we're gonna need to
keep our our information there so let's
just go ahead I'm gonna get rid of all
of these lines so again that's ctrl K
ctrl K and this is - used and we're
doing a get to this account and we're
saying all of the messages that were
ever sent from this account let's take a
look at that and we're doing a get so
we're not doing a post so we're gonna
show a list there we go so again you
could format this or make it prettier
but for an L oh let's keep exploring
some more tools
awesome job getting that running on your
local machine feels pretty good doesn't
it what a cool skill you now have you
can send a text message from your
machine with just a single command and
believe me this is just the tip of the
iceberg of what you can do there are so
many more Twilio API is available but
for now let's take things a step deeper
now I don't know about you but I'm a
little clumsy when it comes to long
commands on the terminal like we just
did with curl when exploring api's I
really like to lean on a tool called
postman and I think you'll enjoy it too
why don't you take a quick break and
then we'll check out postman
[Music]
[Music]
postmen is a wonderful feature rich tool
that I use all the time to explore new
api's it started out as a Chrome
extension but recently became a
full-fledged application it's super
handy I love how it can help you
organize your learning and I think it's
an excellent exploratory tool too let's
dive in postman can be downloaded at get
postman calm go ahead and pause me while
you get it installed is right here
download the app and I'll wait and when
you're done unpause me I'll set okay
so here it is I've got it installed too
and when it comes up it will have this
create new and typically when I end up
using this tool I'm working with a
specific API and what I like to do is to
create a collection to keep all of the
requests that I make group together so
I'm going to choose collection here so
create new collection let's recreate
those calls that we made to the Twilio
API using curl so let's do that right
here so we'll call this the collection
name is going to be Twilio and then i'm
just going to click create down here
there's a little window thing little bar
over here you can see that you've got
your your collections over here so we
have a new one here called Twilio
and in here you'll see that we can add
requests so I'm going to go ahead and
click add request so let's build that
message log remember that was the get
that we did over in the terminal so I'll
name this request that request name is a
message log and I like to make a
description here about what is what's
going on here so this will be this is
gonna be all messages sent from my
account that's what we were looking at
right that's what that message log was
um and if I'm taking notes usually what
I do is I drop a link to the
documentation about what the resources
that I'm looking at that way I have a
quick way to get back to it to look at
it so one way to do that is just go find
the documentation so if we just do
Twilio the message resource doc that's
that's what I had there before so that's
going to find the resource for the
messages and a resource reference that's
great
and the way that the code here works
here is very similar to like we saw on
Spotify the different things that are
available there's the create message
resource and each one of these kind of
has its own little heading and there's
some code over here that we can switch
so I want to look for list all messages
that's what we want with the message
list right so I've got this example and
I'm going to grab the URL and I'm gonna
come back over to post me and just drop
it in there and postman uses here this
is markdown so I'm going to use brackets
and say Twilio documentation and then if
I put parens I can paste the link there
and that will make a link inside of my
notes let's scroll down a little bit
here Twilio offers a ton of different
api so I could break this down even
further with this thing called a folder
so let's open this up actually and let's
make a new new folder here because you
know there's so many different API eyes
we might be playing with a bunch of
different things so what I like to do is
put these in folder so let's make a
folder we'll make the folder are called
SMS okay and we're gonna add that to the
SMS folder okay so what this is saying
is we're gonna make this new request
we're gonna create a new folder called
SMS and when we click Save we'll see
that here underneath Twilio we have this
SMS now and there's our message log as
it were so what's happened here is it's
created a tab for our new request that
we've made and you'll notice that
there's a little twisty here and there's
a tab and there's the link to my
documentation which is handy as you'll
see as we're going through this so let's
go grab that URL that we had I'm gonna
go back to my terminal and I'm gonna
press the up arrow and I have that there
if you don't have this go ahead and look
in the notes and I've got a copy for you
so I'm gonna copy that I'm gonna come
here I'm gonna put the request in here
one thing to notice over here is there's
this drop-down that says get and we can
send different types of here's the
different verbs right that we can send
across
HTTP verbs bunch of them and we're gonna
leave it at get right now cuz that's
what we're gonna do we're gonna get the
messages and I think we're all set so
let's go ahead and click send and oh we
got an error you'll see that we got back
a 401 unauthorized so if I mouse over it
I see more information which is nice and
if I scroll down here a little bit
here's the error message that came back
from Twilio it says your account set or
auth token was incorrect and oh yeah we
didn't even pass them so you can add
that authorization she requests by this
little tab here so next to program this
is authorizations and here we'll say
type inherit off from parent oh that's
actually a great idea we're gonna be
using the same account SID and off token
anyways so we should just use it from
the parent right so I'm going to open up
my Twilio collection which is here so if
this the screen ever gets closed this
little guy here pops out so I'm gonna go
to my toilet collection and right click
on the buttons here and I'm gonna choose
edit there we go and we'll come over
here to authorization so what this does
is all requests we'll share this if they
have you know inherit from parents so
whether this authorization it's used for
every request in the collection which is
what we want and we're gonna change the
type to be basic off which is what we're
using there so we click basic off and
look at this we were gonna put our super
secret information here but it's saying
heads-up these parameters hold sensitive
data to keep this data secure while
working in a collaborative environment
we recommend using variables I don't
know about you but whenever I see
security warnings I like to follow that
so let's follow that so let's there's
variables here so it says learn more
about variables if there's also this
variables tab up here right so let's
click into variables okay so what these
do is we create a new name and it will
have a value and people can set on their
own machine there these own values so
this is a good way of not accidentally
sharing out your keys so the things that
we want is we want to have the account
SID which is a string identifier so
Twilio account SID and the way these
work is there's this initial value this
is what people will see when they come
in so we want them to fill out their own
so we'll say your account SID
so if anybody is using this you're gonna
share
that's what they'd see and we'll get the
current value so that's over in my
Twilio console so if I go to Twilio
slash console which is the the main page
which once you log in you'll see here
that I have my account set here it is
and then there's a little copy button so
I'm going to copy my account SID
and we will paste that and the current
value is my account SID and then we'll
do another one we need the auth token
will say Twilio off token I'll say
you're off and again what we want is
this auth token I'm going to copy that
and paste that here awesome and I'm
gonna click update
so I'm gonna go again again and choose
edit and I'm gonna go to authorize a
ssin and now that we have it postman
allows you to use those variables
wherever you want to and you can replace
them by using a curly brace sometimes
those are called mustaches if you look
at that sideways so we'll do Twilio
accounts it right so it's double
mustaches right so mustache much to ask
them then just that
so mustache loops and for the password
we'll do show Passover just so we can
see that we're doing it right well the
mustache mustache Twilio off token
that's how this works there we go
so that is going to set the
authorisation for all of the collections
to these variables that are local to our
machine make sense there we go so we
click OK update and now let's go ahead
I'm gonna close this this window here
that's this little and I'm gonna click
send
ok so we've got the authorization
headers in place we'll click send there
we go beautiful much nicer formatted see
here we got our messages
we got an array of messages that came
back and we have a boyfriend terminal
yeah we should have another one there's
nice URIs that we could go look at other
things like feedback that came for a
matter the the media that's attached to
it and here you'll see the original we
did that was ahoy and you'll see that
the cost of it was zero zero seventh of
a cent it's awesome now that we've got
all of our foundation set up we've got
our collection and we've got our
variables set up let's go ahead and
let's make it so that we can send a post
from this right after a quick break
[Music]
[Music]
so we've got our message logs all set up
in postman so now let's use it to create
a post request now since we want to use
that same authorization that we use in
the message log we should put it in the
collection and folder so let's go back
over here again if this is closed you
click this little icon down here to pop
this out so we're gonna add a new
request inside of the Twilio SMS here
and we're gonna make Adric West in the
request name is going to be create
message
so we'll say creates a text message and
then let's see if I have the toilet
ducks up still I don't so we'll have
again we'll search Twilio message there
it is filling it out for me message
resource reference and over here on the
Left nav we can see that there's
different it's we want this create a
message resource this is definitely what
we want see there's the URL so we will
copy that and bring that back over to
our postman and we'll say awesome and
it's an SMS folder that's when I started
it from let's bring this all the way up
was a saved SMS that's the folder
awesome so we have this create a message
so let's see in order to create a
message remember we're going to do a
post and it's that same URL that we were
using from the get message log so see
how there's two tabs here so I'm gonna
switch back over to my get oh look at
this we see here that the account I said
is in there and we don't necessarily
want to put our account set there for
each and we want anybody who uses this
to be able to use it so let's
change that to use Twilio account
so that will use the variable that we've
created right so it's gonna replace that
automatically here and then you can see
what it is
by mousing over it and let's click send
make sure that we got it cool now this
is a usable URL for anybody if we were
ever to share this I'll show you how to
do that here in a second so we'll paste
this here and when we're creating a
message we're gonna need to send some
additional information right so if we
click over here and we click on this
body tab so we're gonna send some values
and in the CRO command we sent that
using form URL encoded so let's do that
and what were those values though oh you
know I should pop over to the
documentation I am sure glad that I made
that link so I can click here open that
up cool so we definitely need a two
that's right we need it too from since
you may also need to pass a body or a
media URL with the messages content
media URL does I mean I can send
pictures cool we should do that
shouldn't we cool so there's two and
there's from body and media URL okay
cool I'm gonna set this to the curl
language do you see these different
programming languages here we're gonna
set this to curl so it's on the right
format here so there's media URL and the
two and the from have capital F there so
that's the format that we want so we'll
say - and that's my number that we want
to send this to so that's one five oh
three four six one five five three seven
so let's add a body so I'll do body I'm
gonna need to make sure that it's
checked so body and we'll say sent from
postman and you can actually send in
these messages you can send emojis which
who wants a text module with Adam oh
just my frequent use on the muscle taco
frowny love Ryan sent from postman
awesome Pam why don't we send a media
URL we saw that there in the notes oh
it's a media URL
and the URL you could send any sort of
gif or Jif or whatever however whatever
you can send here whatever you want I'm
gonna copy and paste one of my faves
that we can send feel free to use your
own image I've left some fun suggestions
on the notes if you want to copy gif is
a great site to find those so let's see
if we got to body mean do we need from
we need from so that's our Twilio number
so I'm gonna click in here and I'm gonna
say from actually this is something
where this is my personal number so why
don't we add a variable for that so I'm
gonna flip back over here to the Twilio
variable so we'll come back to edit come
in here to variables and we'll add a new
one for call it Twilio number and I'll
say your Twilio number and our Twilio
number let's look at that it's in the
console so Twilio slash console here's
our trial number so what we won't copy
and paste that
yeah we'll paste that here there we go
so update and so the from value weakens
use Twilio number awesome alright this
is feeling good to me here it goes
nothing
we're gonna click send and boom 201
created awesome and I just got my text
message and there's my gift pretty cool
right so creating an MMS or multi
messaging service message is a lot more
difficult the miss if you were to
attempt to do that by scratch but the
abstractions in place right so it was
pretty much seamless for us now you'll
notice here that the message says maybe
you won't notice the status here says
queued but if we go and we look at our
message log and we run this thing again
we can see that there's our central
postman there's our emoji and and here's
some more information and if we scroll
down a little bit more we'll see these
sub resource urs and now we can see this
media that was sent along so let's go
ahead and I'm gonna just click this
and watch what it does it's gonna make a
new get request now there's a bit of a
problem because this get request is
outside of our collection so typically
when I need to do something like this
there's a little hack that you can do so
can get the authentication information
so let's just click Save and I just call
it you can just call it that if you want
to and I'm just going to call it temp
because we'll delete it when we're done
here so what is called temp save that to
SMS and when we run this we'll see that
we got back the list of medias and
because you can send multiple right you
can send multiple pictures in a and
we'll see here that there is an official
one and see how it is accounts and then
messages and then media they're their
sub resources so I'm gonna go ahead and
I'm going to click on that and if we
wanted to we could run this request and
it would be it would show information
about the media but if you actually
remove this JSON it will show the form
of whatever the media was so we'll make
this request and watch what happens
see we got back my my gift that I said
and with a request of this size we
probably don't want to be making that
request again if we don't need to so
this sounds like the job for client-side
caching let's see if our API supports
caching tricks so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna expect the headers that are on
this response nice so it has this last
modified header here which is a good
sign that it does support caching so
let's go ahead let's copy this value so
I'm gonna copy this date here into the
clipboard and if I go up to where my
request was made if I come into headers
here I can add a new header and I'm
gonna say if and you'll see that postman
is doing a really good job of showing
what's available so if it's been
modified since that time because this is
basically what your client would do
right it says if this thing has been
modified since this time then show me
anyone otherwise don't so that's that's
what this does so I'm going to go ahead
and I'm gonna go ahead and click send
and you'll see that my API returns this
I'm not modified so our API supports
caching which ding-ding-ding
means we covered another part of restful
api constraints using standard HTTP
caching mechanisms like last modified
and etags a restful api should support
caching it's up to you to maintain the
cache on your client and decorate your
request but this can come in really
handy to avoid making unneeded requests
awesome so let's make sure that we've
got these saved you see these little
orange dots here means that they haven't
been saved so I'm gonna click on it and
click command S or ctrl s and I don't
really care about the temp
and I don't really care about this one
that was just kind of exploring so let's
take a look here we have this temp we
can choose and say delete and we'll
delete it from temp and now we have just
have our message and our create message
a one more quick thing before I wrap up
I wanted to show you you can actually
generate code from from this so if you
click in here you can see here's an
example of generating a code snippet
it's going to actually run through the
code and set up everything that you need
to to run this code now there are things
called helper libraries that will do
this and Twilio has one and we'll look
at that here in a second but this is
pretty slick right really really
powerful and you just copy it to the
clipboard and boom pretty powerful huh
awesome job diving into postman it's a
super powerful tool and it keeps getting
better every day there are so many
features that we didn't even cover we
barely scratched the surface check the
notes for where to learn more we saw how
to organize our requests together into
collections as well as share common and
secure values by using variables we
learned how to add different values to
your requests both in form values and
headers and we also saw how to navigate
through various sub resources by
clicking you our eyes we even saw how to
create actual runnable code from your
request while we were in the Twilio
documentation you might have noticed the
code examples on the screen on that page
it's possible to tab between various
language implementations and solutions
many products offer what is known as an
SDK or software development kit or
helper library that allows you to
interact with their products in your
native language as you can see it
abstracts away the rest api completely
let's take a look at the Twilio helper
library next before that though just a
quick reminder to make sure that you
check out the notes on this video
there's a link to a repository of built
out collections that are ready for you
to use there are lots of great api's to
practice with postman and curl are both
great tools for accessing and exploring
api's however when it comes time most
likely you're gonna need to write some
code as we saw in postman you can
actually generate code all programming
languages come with some sort of way of
making requests and as you know HTTP
requests are all we really need to
interact with REST API now writing that
sort of code is totally fine but you'll
find out that you end up writing a lot
of what is known as boilerplate code now
by boilerplate I mean code that is
repetitive and almost always the same
just with a few tweaks many products and
services have created a solution to help
you avoid this problem they're often
called helper libraries or SDKs software
development kits
they'll be specific to your programming
language these libraries help to make
your code more concise and legible they
usually also provide additional
documentation for your editor which I
find super handy let's go check out some
of these helper libraries let's explore
both a JavaScript and Python helper
library in order to do that I'd like to
make sure that you have both node and
Python installed on your computer I've
put installation instructions in the
notes let's get started with node so I'm
going to open up the terminal on my Mac
and I'm going to make a directory called
scratch and I'm gonna change into that
directory and in here I'm gonna make a
directory called JavaScript and I'm in a
CD into that directory and I'm gonna
open my editor in this directory here so
I'll say code I'm using Visual Studio
code so we can open up visual studio
code and over here in our directory I'm
going to add a new file and I'm going to
just call it Explorer is alright what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna install the
library and in node land that is called
NPM so I'll open up a little terminal
here in Visual Studio code and I'm gonna
run NPM install Twilio
and that's going to go out and it's
going to get the library so that I can
use it and I can use it like so now now
I can say Const Twilio goals require
Twilio and then we're going to
initialize it
so we'll say Const client equals new
Twilio and as you can see it takes an
account SID and an auth token and I have
those available for us here so here's my
account Sid I'm going to copy that and
we will make the auth token after that
yeah alright awesome now can you think
of anything wrong with doing that with
putting my account Sid and off token
there well right now this is just
sitting on my machine but if I were to
upload or share this with anyone my
credentials are sitting right there
waiting for anyone to steal typical
solution here is to use environment
variables and we'll do that when we
build our application but this is just a
friendly reminder be careful with the
keys what we're gonna go over here might
very well be overwhelming but it will
make sense someday if you stick with it
I promise I've added notes but really
don't let this stress you out the reason
why I'm talking about this behavior is
because the Twilio JavaScript client
works like most JavaScript libraries
it's asynchronous and it relies on a
concept called promises so the way that
promises work is that you set up
handlers for when your method call
actually completes so to get our message
log we use this method there's a method
called so we do client top messages dot
lists and what that method returns is an
object that is called a promise it's a
promise of a future value the future
value in this case will be our messages
so
mrs. have an important method on them
and it's called then so I'm going to go
ahead and chain on that message so I'll
say dot then and this method should be
given a function that accepts a value so
I'm gonna pass it a function now in
modern JavaScript you can use what are
known as fat arrow functions so what
I'll do is I'll put the name of the
value and the value here is messages
right because this is what I'm expecting
to be returned and then I'm gonna put a
fat arrow which is an equal sign of
greater than and then I'm gonna put the
function body so let's just log out the
most recent message okay so we'll do
console dot log and I'm going to use
back ticks so that we can get a string
interpolation and I want it to be the
first one in the array so we're gonna
say the most recent message is dollar
sign curly brace messages zero because
it's an array dot body and that is a
long line and this happens quite a bit
so typically what we do is when we do
this chain as we press ENTER here and we
put that on its own line still pretty
long still off the screen and if I ask
this to format with prettier let's see
what it does there we go so you know
it's it's not a pretty good job of
getting things close so and then again
just to show you that this is running
asynchronously I'm gonna below making
this call right so this looks like it's
after that calls made well it is after
that calls made is just that calls gonna
be asynchronous I'm gonna say gathering
your message so let's go over it real
quick what's going on here is that we
are getting a hold of the client and
we're setting up a new client so that
all requests made against this client
are authenticated right so that's our
account CID and our auth token and then
we're going to use the client we're
going
use the messages route there we're gonna
do a list and that list is a tin
asynchronous method now while this has
been abstracted away we know what this
is doing it's making that same get
request that we did in postman and in
curl and we know that it will return a
JSON response but because this is
asynchronous immediately it's going to
move on to the next line it's gonna say
gathering your message log and when that
call to list returns it's going to run
this function and it's going to pass in
the return value of that response to
here now you should note the return
value here is an actual object it's not
a JSON response that sneaky little
helper library of ours has also
abstracted that away for us it took that
HTTP response which has a body of JSON
and it automatically turned it into an
object for us and you can see that here
it's an array of objects right so it's
at the zero if okay so let's run it so
I'll do clear down here and we're gonna
say node Explorer j/s so we should see
gathering your message log and then the
most recent message fingers crossed here
we go awesome yes okay now one thing
that we should make sure to do here is
to capture any errors that might have
happened a synchronously right now if an
error happens it'll be swallowed well
actually let me demonstrate what that
means this bites me all the time and I
don't want it to bite you let's say that
you accidentally trimmed the last
character off up here the seven of mine
let's take the last one off here so I'm
just gonna do that so it's an invalid
SID
and I'm gonna save and I'm gonna run it
it's gonna say gathering your message
log and then it's just gonna end out no
error no nothing
but the results never came back so what
we need to do is we need to catch any
errors that might occur every promise
has a method named catch and what might
not be clear here is that this then here
that's returning this is actually also a
promise so I can just chain on here so I
can say dot catch
and I'm going to catch an error and
again fat arrow function and we'll just
log that here so say console not error E
or R okay so now we've got it's gonna
chain and if anything happens it's gonna
send the error so let's let's try that
again let's see what happens now with
our catch in place awesome
tells us that it wasn't found because
that's wrong right great this is
probably a good time to remind you if
that was way too much information that
you can and you probably should scrub
the video back and watch me do it again
I guarantee that you'll catch some stuff
you missed the first time and at the
very least you'll spot a dad joke that I
made at the very beginning of this video
I had said this will make sense
eventually I promise I'm sorry I'm kind
of obligated to make that joke and if
that doesn't make sense yet that's also
okay check the teachers notes for more
information on promises let's change
gears and take a look at the Python
version of the helper library right
after a quick break I know I need one
see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we just took a look at the Twilio
JavaScript helper library and now let's
take the Python helper library for its
bed now if you don't have Python
installed pause me and check the
teachers notes for instructions in my
turbo I from my scratch directory I'm
gonna create a new Python directory so
say I'm like make derp Python change
into that and while we're here let's
just check and make sure that we have
the right version of Python so I'm
running Python 3.73 as long as this
first 3 here is a 3 and not a 2 we're
good to go Python uses a concept of
virtual environments these will allow
you to install packages local to this
application so let's do that just to be
safe so uh so that's done with the - em
and then vim for virtual environment and
I usually just call that dot vim so that
will create a directory called dot vim
that is right there and here we go and
what happens is now I'm on a Mac so this
might look a little bit different on
Windows if you do dot them there is a
directory called bin activate and I'm
gonna source that file I think this dot
bat file on Windows check the nuts and
you'll see now that I am activated so
I've got this dot film here I'm gonna go
ahead and open up my editor so I'll do a
code dot and here we are there you see
my dog vim directory and I'm gonna add
an explorer dot pi alright
and I want to install the Twilio helper
library so do a ctrl tab and you'll see
that my editor actually went ahead and
ran that argument for me so it already
I'm activated here which is good because
I want to install a package here using
pip which stands for the cute recursive
acronym of pip installs packages so
that's P IP install and again Twilio
cool so it's installed and we can start
using it so I'm gonna go up here and
we'll say from Twilio that rest import
client and we'll make a new client and
again it can be instantiated using so
here it's it's giving us this nice
information that's that's available
about the API so we'll put a put in here
again this is our account SID
and boy it really wants to show us that
accounts it and auth token so let's
let's get that
so again account Sid and
and let's let's get these on some new
lines by themselves again really bad
practice to leave your keys out like
this we'll fix that in a bit now let's
print out the call log real quick just
to show off the similarities and
differences between libraries so the
Python version is synchronous right so
we can say so we can just iterate
through those MIT lists of messages so
we can say for message in client the
messages list and we will say print the
message dot body all right let's see
what that looks like so we'll do Python
Explorer PI and I didn't save it so
that's an important part I found it
explored up PI and there we go
sent from postman away from terminal so
awesome so let's go ahead and we'll
comment that out for now because we're
gonna do something else
so those are commented out and let's
write some code to send a new one so
we'll say message equals client dot
messages dot create and in here we are
going to pass our variables so we're
gonna send this to me or to you in this
case five oh three four six one five
five three seven it's my number and the
from now you'll notice that from is a
keyword in Python right so see it's like
from twirly arrest so what's nice is the
Python library has made it from
underscore here it helps for the
reserved words so my number my Twilio
number what was that here it is that's
my Twilio number awesome
and let's do a body and we'll say hey
buddy hello from Python and let's go
ahead let's print things out so Python
has a nice little thing called f strings
which will allow you to print variables
that are in scope so we'll say if I
created a new message and let's just
show the message SID to make sure that
we got it and we can just do MSG dot SID
okay so it starts with an F and it uses
the mustaches around this for message
dots in very similar to those string
literals in JavaScript let's go ahead
and create this one so we will run
Python and Explorer and this should send
a message and it did and again I want
you to see we are abstracting away the
fact that we're posting to the messages
sub resource under my account
it's just magically happening because
we've logged this client in pretty cool
right the other thing that this
abstraction gives us is we have instance
variables that represent our resources
now it might not have been clear up here
when I looped over these objects but
they're actual objects it's not just
data they actually have methods and I
can call the delete method on this
message and it will get deleted fact
that's not a bad idea we've been doing a
lot of test exploratory messages let's
just delete them okay so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to come up here and I
am going to uncomment this code and I'm
going to comment out our creation
message code and let's make this F
string here so we'll say deleting
message body here we are we're gonna say
message dot delete cool now before we
run this I want you to make sure that
you understand the
we're gonna delete all the messages in
your account if you've been using a live
account and have things that you want to
save I highly recommend not running this
okay you've been warned so here we go
I'm gonna update this there we go so
we've just deleted all of our messages
so if we come and try to run it again
you'll see there's no messages to loop
over we've done it clean sleep it's like
that nothing never was pretty cool right
that helper library was able to abstract
away that HTTP delete call and it used
the information that it had available in
its object to make the call itself
awesome you see how the helper libraries
are similar yet match the development
workflow and style of each language this
is one of the key benefits of helper
libraries in general they abstract away
the HTTP client connection of the REST
API boilerplate they also behave as you
expect them to behave it feels natural
the way that we were able to delete from
the resource itself helps to unlock
another REST API constraint scavenger
hunt item and that is uniform design now
this constraint has four subsections one
of which is what we just discussed
resource manipulation through
representations because there was enough
information included it was clear how to
modify and delete this resource another
subsection in here is resource
identification in requests those are the
URIs that are included because the URIs
are included we know that we can get and
manipulate specific resources uniform
use of the HTTP verbs is pretty powerful
we just wrote some scripts
that make use of helper libraries these
libraries are super handy for automation
based tasks or batch scripting making a
whole bunch of calls at once what we're
talking about this we should cover
another common tool for talking to
external api's and that is the CLI or a
command-line interface there's that I
again command-line interfaces can be
used to make API calls from an
executable on your machine more and more
these are showing up for all sorts of
tools that require authentication and do
a bunch of different services this
concept is popular amongst cloud
providers we're setting something up
needs to be done quickly from the
command line check the notes form or
another common place where you'll use
helper libraries is from within
applications that you're building let's
get to the
final unit of this course and implement
an external API into existing web
applications you've got this by now I
hope you're starting to see that
external API is allow you to add pretty
incredible features to your applications
want to send a slack message when
someone fills out feedback on your
website there's an API for that want to
change the color of your lights in your
house when your favorite sports ball
team scores there's an API for your team
and for your lights if you want it want
to send yourself a text message ten
minutes before your bus shows up api's
are there too heck do you want to make a
Furby dance it's got an API they're
everywhere and give you lots of power
we've seen how to use them from the
command line and we've seen them used in
scripts but now let's take a look at
embedding them in a web application I've
gone ahead and build the starts of a web
application for us to play with now one
thing I know I don't do enough of is to
compliment my friends and family and
even co-workers sometimes the web can be
so negative so I was thinking what if we
made a web app that did the opposite of
that introducing complementor so the way
it works is you fill out a webform
for who you're complimenting along with
their mobile number you say why they're
great and they get a text message
telling them how great they are and an
encouragement to do the same and of
course they will and when they come and
see the messages that have been sent by
everyone else they'll be pleasantly
surprised pretty sure we have a viral
success here so if there happened to be
any venture capitalists watching that's
my phone number there
now if building and deploying a website
feels a little too much for your current
skill set have no fear I've created a
couple of repositories of code that
we'll be using we're going to use a fun
approachable tool called glitch to host
our websites the website is basically
functioning - our API that we're gonna
add if you haven't used glitch before
it's a collaborative community built
around learning you take existing
projects and you remix them it has an
online editor so I want you to head over
to glitch comm and create a user for
yourself if you haven't done so already
after you're all set let's get to adding
our API to the application first let's
take a look at the Python based web
application we're gonna be using a web
framework called flask flask provides an
API that lets you extend the framework
to create your application this example
application is going to be doing
server-side rendering this means that
the pages will only be created on the
server-side
any
or navigation will require a full page
reload in the notes I've included a link
to the repository where I've got our
starter code so go ahead and copy that
now I'm going to open up glitch comm and
I'm gonna choose new project from here
I'm gonna choose clone from git repo in
here I'm going to paste what I pulled
out and I'm gonna do this is the one for
flask so I make sure that's the one that
says flask I'm gonna click OK I've been
having a couple of problems with this
sometimes this will just sit here and
say loading project if it does just try
that same thing a couple of times let's
see what happens here sort of times out
a little bit I guess it's safe to say
that glitch is glitching no that's not
fair there must be some sort of bug
that's happening right now
I'm experience it I'm going to record
this just in case you run into it too
just do it a couple times if that
happens I do want to point out that it
is pretty amazing what glitch is doing
it's pulling this over it's sending up a
whole new environment for us in a web
server that can run and I actually have
one that's up and running I did the same
thing where I made a new project you'll
notice I'm not even signed in so that's
fine they let you not even sign in and
create these things okay cool so here we
are down here under tools there's a
thing called logs that you can open up
and it will show you what happened this
is what happened though it's set up on
our web server here and you'll see that
the server is actually running and if
you come up here you can go and click on
show and the sunglasses here your future
so bright you've got to wear shades so
you can click view in a new window
and you'll see that the application is
up and running which is awesome right
and this URL here this is all yours you
can use it to do whatever so the
application itself it's pretty simple
it's just the page with the form and
this section in here provides messages
when they eventually come in but as of
right now we don't have any because we
just released all those right but as of
right now we don't have any way to send
text messages we don't yet have the
Twilio helper library installed in this
application so let's go back over here
so these are the files that are
available over here so you can see
here's a pie
and there's some settings that you can
do up here you can come in here you can
actually change the name of this to be
whatever you want to be so I'm going to
call this complementor and we'll say
compliment your friends cool and this is
another nice thing you can do is you can
change the theme I'll put it on dark
theme I don't know when you're watching
this but this should be okay both in
light and dark so there you go
you can also delete this if it's not
something that you want if you ended up
creating something so cool awesome so
this app dot pie this is our program
flask works by creating an object called
app so you do this flask name and it
creates this thing called app and then
what you can do is you can put different
routes in here so so for instance when
we go to forward slash which is the
index page right it's gonna do a get and
it's going to render this template of
index.html and that is in here under
static templates index dot HTML then
you'll see here this is how the page is
laid out there's some dynamic data here
we're using some if and it's going to
loop through messages you should they
exist and we'll look at how that works
here and then we'll see there's a form
that's doing a post to add compliment
let's look back at apt up PI and see how
these two line up so it's going to come
in and it's gonna call get sent messages
and get sent messages it's not
implemented I left this here as I to do
so we can fix that as it goes so and
then it basically pushes those messages
and since it's an empty list it will
just go so in here we can see that
there's an add compliment and it's
happening when a post happens so it's
going to run this function when this
when a post happens and again that post
was happening from the forum we'll see
what's happening is it's just pulling
off these variables we've got sender
receiver complement that's pulling off
too and if we take a look at back up
here if we look at our forum we'll see
that we've got there's the two and
you'll see the name is two so that's
what's getting pushed across and their
sender and receiver and compliment so
they're pulling us through
it's kind of building a message for you
so if cinder says and she's in that F
string right Sanders's receiver is
complement see more at request URL and
we'll send that message to body so is
gonna call send message and right now
send message is needed to be filled out
so this to do here is actually a pretty
good place to start right we need to
send the text message otherwise there's
no messages to show and we know how to
send text messages using a restful api
no sweat we can do that so I could use
the Python HTTP client and write my own
messages that seems like a lot of extra
work right so I'm gonna use the Twilio
helper library so in glitch you can
access the terminal from your
application by down here if you go into
this clip tools and you come up here to
logs and then come over here to console
and see that I've now got a terminal
running which is pretty powerful right
so I'm gonna type source dot and then
it's in dot VM bin activate remember we
had done that before so we're gonna
activate scrip now we're activated and
you'll notice that I've got this this
here this vim so now I will go ahead and
I will do a pip install Twilio so we'll
get down that Twilio helper library so
that we can use it in this application
awesome so it's all installed so we
should be able to use that I'll go ahead
and close this and it went and it
downloaded everything that we needed
right so it got it but if someone was to
come along later and use it the way that
it knows what to install is there's a
requirements dot text file and you'll
notice the Twilio stuff isn't in there
this has just got the stuff for flask
Ginger's part of flask and FERC so he's
also part of flask it's got just the
stuff that was needed so they won't have
the Tullio library so we want to get the
twiddle library in here so the way to do
that is let's get back in here into the
console so first again we're gonna
activate source them in activate ok so
we're going to use pip freeze to show
all of the packages that we have
installed
and then we can store its output and we
can do that in this requirements dot
text I'm going to go ahead and do that
and when you make a change in the
console you have to do refresh to make
sure that it shows up so now if we look
in here we will see that we have Twilio
is now available for whoever comes to
use this later
cool let's write some Python okay so
back in App dot pi I'm going to come in
here and I'm gonna say from Twilio dot
rest import client so this line here
this load dot M will load environment
variables from a secret glitch file that
I have over here this dot M I started it
for you now why don't you pause me and
go get your keys and phone number and
fill this file out this is kind of like
the environments that we saw in postman
so go get those do you know where
they're at go ahead pause me and when
you're all ready unpause me and I'll
show you how I did it ready okay so
here's how I did it I went to my Twilio
console and I copied my account SID and
then I went and I went to my off token
and I copied that and I pasted that
there and then of course my Twilio phone
number is my trial phone number right
here and I'm gonna paste that here
yeah and save that I don't need that
there we go cool so let's flip back to
app dot pi and if we take a look here
there's a thing called Twilio phone
number and it's using this OS get in for
a get environment Twilio phone number so
it's pulling that from here so in our
application automatically this will be
set up nobody else can see this this is
your personal information but here I've
got that stored in a variable pretty
cool right so let's go ahead and let's
create one of those clients right so
what's that client equals client and
here's a little fun fact if you don't
pass any arguments to the client object
on creation it will look in your
environment variables for those Twilio
underscore values
so like the Twilio account said so
environment variables are an excellent
way to keep your keys hidden and not
leave them sitting in the front seat
check the notes for how to do that
locally on your machine so now we have
an authenticated client that we can use
to complete these two dues so the first
one I think we should do is tackling
that sending the message right that was
down here we're gonna send this message
I'm gonna come in here and I'm gonna
delete this keyword called pass and I'm
gonna start with actually you know what
you got this go ahead and write the code
to send a message now don't worry if you
didn't memorize the syntax I've put
links in the notes to the Twilio dogs
ready pause me and write the code to
send a message using the to the body
which is coming here right so we got the
two and the body coming in and all you
need to do is set the from and you can
set that from your Twilio number here if
you do it right and fill out the form
you should get a text to your phone
number you got a text your number so a
couple of gotchas in python spacing
matters so make sure that your indented
under the function see how this is
indented here make sure you're there and
remember that from F ro M from is a key
word in Python so it's from underscore
right you ready go ahead write some code
to send a message pause me and then I'll
show you how I did it ready you got this
okay how did you do so here's how I did
it so I use the client and I use
messages create and I passed in two and
that's the what's coming in from the
function there in the body there's also
what's coming in from the function there
and then I had to use from underscore
and I want to say the Twilio phone
number awesome and I'm going to click
the show in a new window cool so we're
gonna text my number here so that's plus
one five oh three four six one five five
three seven and we're gonna complement
me person the compliment is Craig we're
gonna say Craig Craig Craig Craig is
completing two dues
and we're gonna send the compliment and
I should get a text that says that my
message was sent successfully and
awesome
I got it and now I'm gonna remove that
to do I don't that feel good I love
removing to do is there's nothing
nothing better than that so what do you
say we get the next one let's do it we
can do this make this return a
collection of messages that were sent
from the number should we do it let's do
it
so get sent matches just is used in this
index function right so that's what's
pulling out the messages so let's take a
look again real quick at that template
yeah so it's saying if messages if there
are any messages for message in message
write out the message body so that's
going to just loop through those
messages so we are going to pass through
the message object then a list of those
message objects so in this get sent
messages we see that it's an MP array so
if that's why it's never showing up so
we want to replace this with a call to
get the client call log right do you
remember how we did that okay you have a
link to the doc so go ahead give me a
pause and see if you can't get it if you
get it and refresh the page you should
see the message and recent messages
ready pause me I'll show you how I did
it after you unpause you've got this
okay this is how I did it so I used
client thought messages that list and
remember we could be using an account
that has multiple numbers so we really
only want to get the messages that were
sent from our Twilio number so again
that's from with an underscore and we'll
do Twilio phone number so that's a way
of querying that right so we're saying
we only want messages that were sent to
the Twilio phone number and if i come
over here and refresh there it is Craig
says Craig is completing to do see more
compliments at HTTP complimentary glich
me so yours will be whatever yours is
they're pretty cool right great job
getting that application up and running
because it's actually running you could
totally share that out now by sending a
text message to someone you trust wait
well actually maybe you can't I seem to
remember something about our accounts
being limited
verified numbers only while in trial
mode now API limits are probably
something that we should look into
really quick since they're pretty common
with every API that you might encounter
let's take a quick detour and explore
some limits and then we'll get right
back to implementing this app in a
full-stack JavaScript app api's are
designed to have limits as you can
imagine if you were the maintainer of a
web-based API
you wouldn't want someone making
millions of requests in a short period
of time now chances are your API server
couldn't support the load the typical
solution to do this is to throttle or
limit the number of requests that you
can make per second typically these
limits are introduced when you get your
API keys if you'll recall on the Tullio
console where we got that trial number
we were informed that not only will
messages we send during the trial have
that trial text that we've been seeing
it also said that we can only send to
verified numbers what do you say we see
what happens if we try now I don't know
about you but I find that having people
that support you in your life to be
super important now for me hands down
that person's my mom like no matter what
I'm doing she's just there and the
sidelines cheering me on
whenever I want something new you can
pretty much guarantee that she's helped
me test it out so I'd like you to do
this I'd like you to think of someone
like that in your life and I'd like you
to send them a compliment using
complementor so I'm gonna add my mom
here so I'm gonna add her number and
that is this one 602 609 five eight one
three so used to just press a mom on the
phone right so I'm gonna say my name is
Craig and I'm complimenting mom and mom
is infinitely supportive as you'll soon
see I'm sure
so obviously you should put in your
friend or family colleague here here we
go all right so I'm gonna click send
column it an new internal server error
yuck let's go and look at our logs and
see what happened so we've got a pretty
big stack trace here of what happened on
ad complement if we come down here it
says the number is unverified trial
accounts cannot send messages to
unverified numbers oh right verify oh we
convert
by them at twitter.com for five let's go
ahead and do that can i I can do that
that's cool go to awesome so now I need
to get my mom's number in here I need to
get her to be verified so that she can
see it so you can actually do this
pretty easily and what this will allow
me to do is to be able to have my trial
account be able to text her which is all
we need right so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to click Add and that you can
we'll call you with a verification
number or I'm gonna make it text you
instead so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna put in my mom's number here put in
602 six oh nine five eight one three so
what I'll do now before I click the text
me as I say hey mom I'm texting here
this it's me again hey I'm gonna verify
your number you're gonna get a text from
Twilio can you send it back to me and
she wrote back sure thing sweetie no
okay
so now that I know she's ready I'll now
send that validation message and so I'll
click text me and I will wait for my mom
to tell me what that was and and she
should be able to send me the code okay
so she texted me and that number is nine
four six five four one and when I click
Submit awesome so now my mom is verified
here she is she's in this verified
numbers now I can text her now let's go
try that again let's get back to this
internal server error and I'm going to
refresh reload that and it's gonna say
hey you're gonna submit the form again
that's totally fine that's what I want
it to do it's actually what I wanted to
do and we say continue boom we did it
and my mom should get a message and she
did she just sent me an emoji heart I
hope you're now able to show off your
app to your supportive person it's
really nice to have that support as
you're learning and building things if
you don't have someone like this my
mom's pretty supportive if you want to
just text her a bit she'll shoot you
back some words of encouragement now of
course this app isn't going to go viral
in this trial mode but this is a great
prototype of the concept most of the
time api's will give you a check
to get your prototype together before
they start charging you being aware of
the limits will help you plan your
efforts remember to carefully read the
limits and error messages most api's
will guide you into how to deal with the
limitations now let's get started with a
JavaScript based implementation of
complementor now we're going to
implement that same complimentary this
time using javascript I've got a full
stack JavaScript application mostly
built and ready for us to tweak by full
stack JavaScript I mean the server is
written in JavaScript and there's some
front-end code that's also written in
JavaScript on the server side the
application uses nodejs and the web
framework Express on the front end I've
used the client-side framework view the
Python version that we saw earlier was
all server-side there are some things to
consider when implementing a client-side
application when using an API so let's
explore those while we get this
javascript prototype up and running in
the notes I've supplied a link to the
repo that you can use to create a new
glitch project go ahead and copy and
paste that I'm gonna click clone from
git repo and then I'm gonna paste of the
repo alright so we're gonna do the node
version so this is node and again if
glitch takes a while to spin up that's
okay it might eventually show up or it
might glitch out and if it does glitch
out like this like sometimes I might
just say the assets folder just go ahead
and do it again and it'll eventually
work for you awesome here's mine working
the JavaScript version of this project
is implemented as a very simple single
page application or s.p.a now what that
means is that once the page is rendered
the client will be responsible for
rendering parts of the page we won't
rely on a full page reload from the
server to load new pages for us let's
take a look at app KS the server side of
our application so we're gonna look at
app dot J yes so let's see this first
dot M here this will load up our
environment variables which we'll take a
look at here in a second and then it's
using Express which is a web framework
and you'll note that it's exposing
static files in a public directory so
this is this is a single page
application and it's rendered in public
in
XHTML let's take a look there public
index dot HTML so this here is a the
view dependency if you haven't seen view
before no worries this is a pretty
straightforward way of using it so what
view does is it uses these V - right so
it's these V - attributes and those are
view specific so basically this is
saying if the complements that length is
greater than 0 and we'll see how
compliments is defined here in a bit and
as you can see if it does exist it's
gonna loop through each one of the
complements and then it's gonna write
them out so it's gonna write them out
using that double mustache syntax here
so it's going to write out the
compliment that's in this loop okay so
that compliments variable is initialized
in our application let's scroll down to
it I've put the whole application in one
single file here so we don't need to
worry about packaging or anything so the
way that you create a new view app is by
saying new view and you can see here
there's this data attribute now as
you'll see compliments is initialized as
an empty array you can add instance
methods to your application by adding a
methods object in the view constructor
so we have a method here called refresh
compliments now you might not have seen
this before but if you've had a hard
time keeping track of promise based
codes in the past this feature here is
the one that you've been awaiting for
you'll see here that the keyword async
is before the name of the function so it
says async refresh compliments once a
function is labeled as asynchronous you
can now cause functions that return
promises to behave synchronously meaning
they don't move on to the following line
until it completes so this line here
makes a fetch write so fetch returns a
promise but there's a key word here of a
weight right before it and this code
will wait for the fetch call to complete
and then assign the future value of
whatever this is into the response and
the same is true here response that JSON
returns a promise and this will wait
until this is done one thing to note
is that this async function makes it so
that refresh compliments now returns a
promise and that is its return value
will have a ven method that returns this
value now if that doesn't make sense
just yet just you await it we'll just
try and let it all sink in so a dad joke
double whammy sorry I'm kind of
obligated to make all these jokes really
though most devs that I talk to you find
this async/await
more straightforward to use than
promises for code that's actually
synchronous in nature all right so what
is this code doing so it's making a get
request fetch as default method is a get
to a URL of slash API slash compliments
so that's in our server-side code let's
flip back to here to app J s and you
define routes with express using this
app dot get so whatever the the HTTP
method name is so app get slash API
compliments that's what we saw so when
that happens this function here will run
and we'll pass in the request and the
response and here's our first to do so
we want to get the message log so first
before we do that we better install the
Twilio helper library using NPM so I'll
click on tools and then I'll click on
this logs and then I'll click on console
now I'm gonna run NPM install install
Twilio I'm gonna do - - save what that
will do is it will update a file called
package JSON after it installs and this
is much like we saw in the Python
library we did the freeze this - - saved
will update that file so that the Twilio
dependency is there I'll let this
complete
awesome and so now when you make a
change from this side we always need to
say refresh so that we can refresh the
project and see the changes that we made
and so if we look in here under
package.json you can see that there is a
dependency of Twilio great so now that
we have things installed let's go ahead
and update the in the file so that's
this key see this little key in here
this is gonna allow us to put our
information in here so I'm gonna go
ahead I'm gonna grab my account said you
should do the same with yours and grab
my off token last but definitely not
least my phone number
all right and now we can use that in our
code let's go right above this port
ripple is port here we'll make a new
Twilio client and we'll require actually
that probably looks better up top a
little bit more let's move that let's do
that right this is all out of
alphabetical order isn't it let's do
this right here here we go and then we
can instantiate one that will look
better down here so it's a constant
equals new Twilio and again it's gonna
pull from the environment variables of
the Twilio underscore and just to show
you how you do that here so we'll say
Const the Twilio phone number if you
ever wanted to pull something else out
of the environment you use process dot m
dot the thing so the thing was called
Twilio I think it's called phone number
let's double check Twilio phone number
and in Twilio phone number yeah cool
awesome so let's get that message log so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna replace
this so we're getting the compliment so
we're gonna sent messages so this to do
get the list of messages sent from a
specific number obviously Twilio number
there so I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
replace this array with my code and
actually you want to give this a spin
well one thing to note is that the
function is marked async so you can and
you probably should use the keyword a
weight right so this is an async
function so make sure you use the awake
keyword are you ready just make the call
to the messages API to get a list of
messages that were sent to a specific
number like the to-do says now don't
worry if you don't have it memorized I
put a link to the docs in the notes go
ahead and pause me and give it a shot
when you unpause me I'll show you how I
did it ready how'd you do so what I did
was client
top messages don't list and in the
JavaScript client helper library you
pass in an object with the parameter so
we say from not a not a keyword here and
we'll say Twilio phone number and like I
said we should make this be a wait
because we're gonna wait for that to
happen and boom just like that of that
to do well why don't we change when we
take a look let's go I'm gonna change
this to be complement or complement or
that's not very nice complement or j/s
complement
I'm gonna close that and let's go ahead
and we'll do show when we should see the
messages come through oh we we shouldn't
see the message come through yet right
because we aren't passing anything
through we're passing down these
complements all right
let's see let's see if we can get this
next to do done then gather only the
body of those messages for sending that
the client okay oh right because we
don't want to send down the whole
message object to the client so what we
want to do the API is called complements
right and we have an array of text
messages so more importantly though if I
were to send down this message each one
of those messages it contains a bunch of
informations that I don't think we want
to share with everybody that message has
the phone number the people who sent the
message
I should never send information that I
want to keep safe down to the client so
really we only want the body so let's
see I have an array and I want a new
array of just message bodies now to me
this sounds like a great use of the
array dot map function so sent messages
is an erase also sent messages dot map
and the map function map takes a
function that will receive each value in
the array so that will be a message and
it takes a function and if it's on one
line we can skip the return keyword and
just put what we'd like to see so
this compliments array we want to see
the array of message dot body right so
what this is saying is like for each of
these messages in here just returned the
message body and put it in compliments
make sense and then it's going to send
down the JSON representation of that to
our view client should we see if it
works all right we'll save this and now
oh there we go it's working already so
we'll see there's a new one from my mom
and it says mom says Craig is so proud
of you sweetie
oops it's nice it's sweet she wrote back
and that's what I love about having
someone use your applications it looks
like I still have some UI work to do to
make it more clear about what's
happening cuz my mom wrote so proud of
you sweetie in the compliment and that
doesn't make much sense but I feel nice
and again this is using the number this
was not sent from this app you can see
it was sent from the Python app right
this is complimentary Jas but this is
using a different data source and you
know what while we're here why don't we
look at how easy it is to see what the
data was that was sent down from the
server so I'm gonna right-click and I'm
gonna choose inspect I'm gonna click on
this a network tab here and I'm going to
refresh the page and you'll see it make
that request so if I click on this
compliments here you can see here is the
message here's that array that was sent
down right you can imagine that if we
sent down all of those messages we'd
have that data very easy to get so again
this is the developer toolbars if you
say view developer developer tools
you'll be able to see this I'm going to
take a quick break and then I'm gonna
swing right back and finish up the
remaining to do creating a new
compliment
[Music]
we just finished displaying a list of
all the complements and now it's time to
deal with how they get added on the
JavaScript side so let's keep the
front-end code and see what happens so
that is in public indexed at HTML so
here's that form alright so we have this
it's a form that goes to post it goes a
slash add complement and it's got these
V dash models so here's like V - model -
V - model sender that's how view does
data binding so anything in that field
will be bound to that variable and if we
come down to the button here we'll see
that the normal click and won't it will
prevent write so that prevents it from
being submitted and it calls this send
compliment method which is defined in
the method stanza here which is this
send compliment okay so it goes ahead
and it grabs the stuff from the form so
pulls them all off they also happen to
be the same it's in a thing called data
then it uses fetch and it uses it
synchronously right so it's got an a
wait it's going to wait for it fetch to
go and it passes that as JSON and we're
saying that it is JSON and we're passing
JSON up and we're doing a post request
let's go ahead and we'll take a look at
an app J s and we'll see here that we're
using this body parser so any request
that comes in will automatically get
parsed and the way that that looks is so
here's this post right so here's we fail
we fix this get we get rid of these two
dues I forgot to erase those closer to
done all right so it comes in here and
it's posted to API compliments again an
async method so it's going to pull off
of the request body to write so and
because the body parser was parsed it's
automatically inflated here so body of
the two it's going to pull the two off
of the field
and request that body sender request up
by receiver a compliment and it's using
the back tick so it's automatically
filling those out so here we are here's
our to do why don't we just
synchronously create that message you
want to give this to do a try go ahead
pause me I put links in the notes I'll
wait for you to unfollow me and then
show me and you did it how'd it go
here's how I did it so we want it to be
synchronous so I'm gonna go ahead and
use oh wait and I don't really need
anything from the creative message so
I'm not going to assign a return value
and I'll use the fact that the
parameters are the same so I'm going to
say client dot plant the messages dot
create and in JavaScript you can do this
if you have a variable name to it we'll
just set to : - from embody right so
this is just basically because there is
a variable called - it knows to make a
new one called - and this right here
alright so let's give that a go so I
will go ahead and click show here and
I'm gonna send another one to my mom
it's mom no my name's not mom
my name is Craig and I'm gonna
complement mom her compliment is a
really patient tester mom is a really
patient tester so here we go yep there
it is so see right away it came back and
you'll see that the forms cleared so
let's see how it did that so back in the
index.html we have this we posted it and
it got back the data and Anna waited for
the result and then it wrote out the
result and we saw this information come
down so we could actually if we wanted
to we could do view developer develop
tools and we should see in the console
here's the object that got sent back so
it was a success of false oh we forgot
to update that didn't we
once look I think we look at that oh I
forgot to say yeah was it successful
journey there good job glad we caught
that
speaking of catching stuff what happens
if things go wrong so much like before
when we needed to capture the error
using the catch method on promises we
need to do something similar in this
async/await land so we need to use a
standard try catch block now if you
haven't seen that before it's it's
pretty straightforward what you do is
you say try and if any error at all is
thrown what will happen is it will call
this catch block and it's a good way to
handle errors so we're going to catch
that error so the error object has a
status and you can send that down to the
client by saying response thoughts
status and we can do error dot snap so
I'll just pass that status straight
through and this can is chainable so
we'll send JSON I might as well share
what happened so we'll say success is
false for real this time and we'll also
send why don't why don't we send the
message within that error --air dot
message there we go you know what we can
use prettier here too so we're gonna go
click this format this file let's make
this thing prettier ooh nice okay so
we're going to try and if there is a
failure we're gonna send this back and
then otherwise we're gonna go ahead and
sent down the success of true so we got
to break it somehow how should we do
that let's say instead of from let's
make this be 42 the meaning of life and
everything so that is obviously not a
valid Twilio phone number so let's go
ahead and let's bring up complementor
and I'm just gonna oh hit did refresh I
was gonna refresh it and it did for me
so we'll send another message to my mom
my name is Craig to my mom and the
compliment is good at catching ears
okay you know I'm gonna click send a
compliment let's see what happens
ooh look so here we got the error it's a
400 that came back and the from phone
number 42 is not valid CMS capable or
inbound number or short code from your
account it's a better version of it cool
right and let's make sure we don't leave
that in that state so we'll undo that
and save it so I want my mom to give me
another compliment and we are good to go
awesome job
you've now used an external API in two
completely different web frameworks and
paradigms even you should be sending a
compliment to yourself you're
accomplishing great things way to stick
with it one other thing I'd like to take
a quick moment to point out is that the
server code that we wrote you might have
noticed it was prefixed with a forward
slash API server code that interfaced
with a client now here's my question to
you do you think that the API code that
we wrote together should be considered
restful why don't we take a look at our
weathered scavenger hunt card so it's
definitely a client-server architecture
our client happens to be in this case a
view application running in the browser
and our server is a nodejs server but
any client could connect and use this
it's definitely stateless right we
aren't requiring any prior knowledge
about the client well at the moment we
aren't providing any caching information
so we could write we could fairly easily
pay attention to those headers coming in
and respond appropriately it would
require us writing some additional code
and thinking through some edge cases but
we could do it let's put this in the
maybe column yeah for sure right in fact
it's a little layered already our API is
calling another API but our client
doesn't need to know that we could also
add additional functionality and the
contract wouldn't change hmm we haven't
even talked about this one yet and it's
the only optional requirement now
basically this means your API returns
code that is runnable like maybe it
returns an embeddable widget or some
actual JavaScript code this doesn't make
sense on our application and that's okay
I'm gonna drop this one in the new so
we're looking good so far but here comes
the doozy this is so remember this one
has four subsections rut row currently
we're just representing all the
compliments as strings and absolutely no
way to identify them
so we fail this sub requirement and
therefore this whole thing is a No
but let's keep going through the rest of
these pun intended sorry we definitely
do not allow any sort of manipulation of
compliments so this is another fail we
haven't gone over this yet but by using
headers we can tell that this is JSON
the message sent down has a type and it
is clear that it should be JSON decoded
to be used and last but certainly not
least
hattie OS or hate OS is an often
forgotten about part of the restful
constraint and very hard to say the idea
here is that there are links provided to
show off what more you could do with
this and where you could find related
resources it provides you our eyes or
links we did see this in both the
Spotify and Twilio ones however ours
doesn't need to provide links to other
resources
so we don't have a restful api and
that's okay
it works as is it does look like we
could get there pretty quickly if we
wanted to one thing I want you to gain
from that exercise is that you now have
the ability to identify whether or not
an API is restful and I hope that felt
pretty good we've now completed that
scavenger hunt we revealed all the
constraints and I hope that most of
those are pretty clear please don't feel
like you need to memorize those you can
find these same constraints littered all
over the Internet as a prize for
finishing the constraint scavenger hunt
I've dropped links to my favorite rest
API constraint documentation for you to
lean on I've also included links to
popular REST API frameworks that will
help you design restful api s make sure
to check the notes you did it you just
completed a whirlwind introduction to
api's and I hope you see how much power
they can add to your programming journey
by looking at interfaces in general I
hope you're more comfortable with the
idea of not fully understanding exactly
how something is working but still
leaning on that abstraction to build
your tools and applications we do this
all the time with physical object
interfaces and api's or application
programming interfaces aren't all that
different I hope you enjoy taking this
course I know I had a ton of fun making
it if you think someone you know might
benefit from this course share it with
them I'd love to hear your feelings your
thoughts and your dreams so I threw
together a little something using a
smattering of api's to capture your
feedback
if you've got the time I'd love to have
you answer a quick text based survey
text feedback two one five oh three four
six one five five three seven actually
you know what if you want to you can
also just call and leave me a message
too I used an API for that too please
please please keep me posted on your
journey and really I can't wait to see
what you build thanks for hanging out
[Music]